third game of a four game set the braves
have won the first two
kyle wright who will make his second
start a lead off walk here's jeff mcneal
roll toward the right side hole and
echeveria slides but can't make a play
it rolls into right field nimmo goes
first to third and mcneil able to find
the hole on the infield and the mets
have the table set runners at the
corners and nobody out well echeveria
was at double play depth this ball
wasn't hit hard
just
out of the reach of etcher marie and the
mets are in business robinson canoe just
loaded one out no score
right back where it came from a position
perfectly echeveria tries to turn it he
got the double play and got out of it
that ball was sucked but the braves
defense was perfectly placed and robbie
cannot has doubled up bottom of the
second inning with the medicine brave
scoreless leads off of the braves
peterson takes care of ozuna for his
first strikeout of the day one out and
nobody on here's travis darno here's the
payoff pitch and it is in there strike
three call he paints with that slider to
get darnell bottom of the third inning
has the first crack at scoring a run for
atlanta today
and on the ground to third
and duvall in a rundown he's gonna
scramble back he's gonna make it safely
and everybody's safe
fielder's choice in atlanta's got him
loaded nobody out cuny now
instead it's ball four was dead red but
it was off the plate and a basis loaded
walk scores the game's first run one
nothing atlanta give a cuny his third
rbi
freeman's up
on the ground
there'll be only one play because of the
shift no chance to turn two that'll
score riley give freeman an rbi and it's
two to nothing because they had rosario
shifted around with canoe the ball was
hit too far away from the second base
bag to do anything but throw to first
two nothing braves into the top of the
fourth demo with two men on
as this one's on the ground left side
flagged back flipped to second at
chevron's turn and not in time that
would have been an incredible double
play
wow
they're gonna have to check this one too
ella's close
mcneil waits pay off
and he struck him out
matsik continues his dazzling work in
relief more futility for the mets with
runners at second or third it's two
nothing home half of the fourth inning
as the braves lead the mitch two-nothing
that ball's lifted toward left pretty
deep smith going back still going back
at the wall it's gone
that's how you break out of a slump home
run for camargo his first of the
[Music]
a problem year to go back foot and he
just kept that one out over the plate
you spot that pitch it's a good pitch
but when you leave it out over that can
happen go to the sixth inning braves up
three to nothing
on the ground deep hole dansby knocks it
down
and has no play but he saved a run
perhaps with a terrific diving stop to
keep that ball on the infield and
stinker's going to go for a fresh arm
tab first and third now
neato will be the hitter we'd love a
rollover here from neato
he had a lot of bad luck should have
some good luck here second for one first
to two minter gets the double play and
gets atlanta out of the sixth
braves great defense continues braves
leading the match three-nothing conforto
to the plate
fly ball right center acuna on the run
he's going to get there and he kept his
feet
great range by ronald lacuna junior to
shut down the mets in the seventh inning
eighth a little insurance wouldn't be a
bad idea drew smith the new pitcher for
the mets ronald o for two
[Music]
he'll watch this ball rock it out toward
right center field that's off the green
padding hacuna flying towards second
and opposite field double to lead things
off
he's coming live folks four doubles for
cunha and another how easy that swing is
right there when he lets his hands work
like that you see he's got such a pretty
swing
barely swung at that
off the right field wall
freeman one-on-one out
and he ambushes that and rips it into
right field and that's going to score a
big insurance run acuna around third
freeman swinging early in the count
give him
rbi number six two on the day and it's
four nothing atlanta well what he does
so well is he looks for a certain spot
doesn't have to just be fastball it can
be cutter it can be change up if he gets
that spot first pitch
mark malanson will come on and pitch top
of the ninth inning four nothing atlanta
and on the ground slowly that should do
it freddie's got it to the bag we go and
the braves have shut out new york four
nothing
they've won the series out right they
extend their winning streak jeff to five
straight games and a little bit of
everything again for brian snifter's
bunch